>> Trace: TAYLOR SWIFT IS
ALREADY CHANGE THE WORLD OF
MUSIC AND NOW SHE MIGHT CHANGE
THE FUTURE OF LIVE MUSIC
INCLUDING HOW YOU GET YOUR
TICKETS AND HOW MUCH YOU PAY.
WE ARE JOINED BY FORMER SONY
MUSIC
EXECUTIVE JEFF SECKINGER, I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS
THE PAST FEW DAYS.
DU BUY TICKETMASTER'S EXCUSE
SAYING WE JUST ARE NOT READY FOR
THIS TYPE OF DEMAND?
>> IT'S HARD TO BUY IT AT FACE
VALUE, SO NO.
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED HERE IS A
TECHNOLOGY FAILURE, THIS ALL
ABOUT BORING SCALABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE COMMUNITY TO HAVE
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN HANDLE
MASSIVE TRAFFIC.
THIS WAS OBJECTIVELY
UNPRECEDENTED THE DEMAND THAT
CAME IN FOR THIS FOR A BUNCH OF
GOOD REASONS.
THE SITE COULDN'T HANDLE IT.
THAT PART IS THE TRUTH OF WHAT
HAPPENED IT WAS A FAILURE.
>> THEY SAID THEY COULDN'T
HANDLE DEMAND BUT TAYLOR SWIFT
SAYING THERE ARE MULTIPLE
REASONS TAYLOR SWIFT THAT HARD
TIME GETTING TICKETS I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THIS SITUATION
COULD BE IMPROVED MOVING FORWARD
AND KNOCKING TO MAKE EXCUSES FOR
ANYONE BECAUSE WE ASKED THEM
MULTIPLE TIMES IF THEY COULD
HANDLE THIS TYPE OF DEMAND AND
WE WERE ASSURED THEY COULD.
>> MENTION TO YOU BEFORE WE GOT
ON THERE'S LOTS OF OTHER ARTISTS
WHO HAVE HAD THIS PROBLEM,
HARRY STYLES HAD IT -- THIS IS
NOT PARTICULARLY NEW STUFF AND
THIS IS A PLATFORM THAT HAS BEEN
OUT THERE FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
PUTTING ASIDE WHAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY WHICH WAS I THINK
UNPRECEDENTED AND PROBABLY
PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY, IT'S A
PRETTY RELIABLE PLATFORM IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BOOK A STADIUM
TOUR IS, THIS IS PROBABLY THE
ONE THEY ARE GOING TO GO INTO
RATHER THAN SOME NEW START-UP OR
SMALLER PLATFORM TO SELL
TICKETS.
>> Trace: I WAS INTERESTED TO
SEE SOME PUBLICATIONS WERE GOING
AFTER TAYLOR SWIFT AMONG THEM
SLATE IN AN OP-ED SAID
TAYLOR SWIFT IS A CAPITALIST.
GOES ON TO SAY I UNDERSTAND SHE
SHOULD EARN MONEY IN EXCHANGE
FOR HER WORK BUT NONETHELESS IT
SUCKS TO BE TURNING OVER THE
POETRY WHILE CAPITALIST TAYLOR
IS TAKING THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRY
TO SELL ME A CREDIT CARD AND YET
ANOTHER SHIRT, KIND OF A ROUGH
TAKE.
>> FOR SURE BUT SHE'S DOING A
LOT OF GREAT THINGS CREATIVELY
AND ON THE BUSINESS FRONT.
HERE, SHE AND LIVE NATION WERE
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
THEY WANTED TO PUT TICKETS IN
THE HANDS OF HER FANS FIRST.
THEY ALSO WANTED TO BE SMART
ABOUT PRICING STRATEGY TO PUSH
BACK ON SCALPERS ON THE
SECONDARY MARKET.
YOU SEE THIS A LOT, SPRINGSTEEN
HAD A LOT OF FLAK AS WELL AROUND
PRICES.
THIS IS WHAT IT IS, THERE ARE
BOTS THAT ARE OUT THERE IT'S NOT
A PERFECT SITUATION, SHE IS A
CAPITALIST FOR SURE.
THESE GUYS HAVE BEEN THROUGH
PANDEMIC THEY LOST TOURING FOR
TWO OR THREE YEARS YOU CAN
EXPECT TO SEE IT AND LOOK AT THE
DEMAND I THINK SOMEONE SAID SHE
WOULD HAVE TO DO 900 SHOWS TO
MEET ALL THAT DEMAND.
>> Trace: SHE IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE LYING ON HER WHAT YOU
MAKE OF THESE CONGRESSIONAL
CALLS TO BREAK UP LIVE NATION
TICKETMASTER.
>> NOT VERY MUCH RIGHT NOW I
THINK THERE ARE SOME PRETTY
FUNKY STUFF IN TERMS OF THE WAY
THIS BUSINESS IS STRUCTURED AND
IT'S TOTALLY FAIR TO LOOK AT
THAT.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF ATTENTION
WHEN THAT MERGER WAS PUT
TOGETHER WITH DOJ APPROVING IT
12 YEARS AGO.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
EXCLUSIVITY BETWEEN VENUES AND
TICKETING SERVICES.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE I WOULD
LOOK TO FREE THINGS UP RATHER
THAN SURGICALLY PULLING THE
WHOLE THING APART THAT DOESN'T
SOUND TOO REALISTIC TO ME.
>> Trace: I WANT TO PUT THIS
UP ON THE SCREEN THIS IS
TICKETMASTER STATEMENT WHEN I
FINALLY APOLOGIZE WE WANT TO
APOLOGIZE TO TAYLOR AND ALL OF
HER FANS ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
HAD A TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE TRYING
TO PURCHASE TICKETS WHILE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE FOR EVERYONE TO GET
TICKETS TO THESE SHOWS WE KNOW
WE CAN DO MORE TO IMPROVE THE
EXPERIENCE AND THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE FOCUSED ON.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY REALIZE WE
ARE IN THE HOT SEAT AND WE NEED
TO COME OUT WITH A BETTER
EXPLANATION THAN "IT'S TAYLOR'S
FAULT."
>> SOMEONE NEEDS TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO MANAGE MORE TRAFFIC
BECAUSE THIS COULD HAPPEN AGAIN.
ON A COMMERCIAL LEVEL SHE'S GOT
TEN OUT OF THE TOP TEN TRACKS ON
BILLBOARD AND SHE HASN'T BEEN ON
THE ROAD IN FOUR YEARS.
PROBABLY COULD'VE ANTICIPATED
THIS FOR SURE.